oh but wait a second do I have Rook
takes D2
here wait a second oh my goodness
because if you capture with Pawn I have
rook f8 and finally the queen is getting
out the corner that might actually be
something you don't take the queen no I
play Rook
f8 oh my goodness takes D2 this could be
a blunder and another big turn around uh
Tat's getting nervous I she found it oh
no my goodness what a turn of events I
mean tatf was just playing Queen B3 to
put on the finishing touches of a
position she had complete control over
chess is brutal oh this is panic time
right now the problem is Queen to B1 is
met by Rook to D1 exactly change up whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Queen
B1 on the
board Rook f8 again
it's oh and queen takes G7